تحولت شوارع المدن الكرديه في ايران الى
ساحه حرب بعد ارسال السلطات الايرانيه
قوات حربيه وتعرض الاهالي لحمله قمع في
وقت تتواصل فيه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في
جوان رود ومها باد وسندج غيرها من المدن
ايضا في اطار التظاهرات التي لم تهدا منذ
شهرين متابعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ههه
تقارير حقوقيه اشارت الى منع النظام
الايراني ايصال الدم الى المستشفيات في
مدينتي جوانرود وبراند شهر وتضامنا مع
المدن الكرديه غربي ايران دعت مجموعه تطلق
على نفسها الشباب الثوار في ايران الى
اغلاق المحلات والاعمال التجاريه يوم غد
في عمومي اراده كما طلب مركز تعاون
الاحزاب الكرديه في ايران المنظمات
السياسيه والنشاطاء المدنيين وكافه فئات
الشعب الايراني بتنظيم اضراب عام يوم غد
ايضا من اجل تعزيز الوحده والتضامن ودعم
الشعب الكردي بالتزامن دار السينما
الايرانيه رفعت السلطه عاليه واكدت انه في
حال عدم انتهاء التهديدات والاعتقالات
والاستدعاءات المتتاليه لاعضائها وعدم
الافراج عن السينمائيين الموقفين فانها
ستطلب من اعضاءها الاعتصام والامتناع عن
التعاون مع المشاريع السينمائيه
والتلفزيونيه ومنظمه حقوق الانسان في
ايران التي تتخذ من اصله مقر كشفت في
تقريرها عن مقتل بتاع 116 شخصا على يد
القوات الامنيه ممن فيهم 51 طفلا وهو 21
امراه ورفضت الى ان 72 شخصا لقوا حتفهم
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]